un homme qui attire la pitié il n'est
plus rien voir mort à l'intérieur voici
comment l'avocate du dentiste décrit son
client
et puisqu'il n'a formulé aucune excuse
l'avocate va le faire à sa place parce
que dit elle il n'a plus de sentiments
et l'avocate du dentiste de se lancer
dans une plaidoirie de près de quatre
heures pour démontrer que les griefs
reprochés à venir up mutilation
escroquerie entre autres ne sont pas
tous bien démontrer ainsi la défense
réclamera la relaxe de son client dans
de très nombreux cas
voulant effacer le surnom de dentiste de
l'horreur que porte l'hollandaise parce
que c'est pas cet homme là que je côtoie
celui que je côtoie c'est celui que j'ai
décrit au début ma plaidoirie
effectivement celui qui mord dedans
il a toujours fui que ce soit fui par le
mandat d'arrêt soit fui par son silence
c'est supposée tentative de suicide
c'est un homme qui fuit face à ses
responsabilités
les violences avec mutilation ne font
aucun doute pour au moins 53 victime
selon la procureure de la république
fustigeant le dentiste hollande et
d'escrocs de menteur de boucher en un
mot de cauchemar du morvan qu'un épais
dossier à câble et la magistrate de
requérir huit ans d'emprisonnement à
l'encontre de van lierop ainsi que
l'interdiction de ne plus jamais pouvoir
exercer son métier
ce dossier qui était extrêmement lourd
pour mes collègues juges d'instruction
du pôle et puisse sortir dans des délais
qui sont raisonnables parce que là
vraiment on avait besoin de ce délai
raisonnable pour les gens qui avaient
l'impression de n'être pas crû depuis
des années le procès du dentiste
hollande est désormais clos son jugement
a été mis en délibéré et la décision du
tribunal sera rendue le 26 avril
en attendant marc venir up retourne en
détention provisoire
il est derrière les barreaux depuis un
an